nesle quelqu'un puis torturé pour le
faire parler c'est encore illégal au
canada district 31 s'apprête à célébrer
son 500e épisode c'est un rêve pour vous
d'un carnet la lieutenant gabriel simard
une femme déterminée métrage humaine
aussi bienveillante ministre vous avez
vous avez quelque chose à dire avec ce
personnage que vous avez vraiment
vraiment vraiment j'aime beaucoup que la
description vous en faites
parce qu'au départ c'était pas tout à
fait seul ça a été dit s'il la trouve et
ex pense au temps pour moi même pour le
coup si on la cherche et fenêtres
finesse qu'elle va être bonne pour le
district ou pas mais avec le temps j'ai
pris ma place puisque je me suis assurée
dans ce que j'avais envie de dire aussi
comme artiste comme femme avec ce rôle
là parce que manger j'ai réalisé à mon
âge les femmes actrices on est souvent
la mère de quelqu'un on existe beaucoup
à travers la maternité
nos personnages féminins pas que d'en
voir une comme ça que son existence
propre avec ses causes et ses causes à
elle qu'à défendre tout ça c'est un
cadeau
justement qu'est-ce que vous aviez à
dire en tant qu artiste qu'est ce que
vous vouliez dire à travers la lune mais
je pense que c'était très confrontant
pour beaucoup de monde et pour moi aussi
d'avoir à quel point une femme en
position d'autorité qui peaufine film
que du caractère ça passe très mal dans
la société qui sont pas au dessus des
lois
je me suis dit si quand je suis arrivé
le lieutenant ça avait été un homme qui
aurait été mal engueulé de même tout
mais que depuis le début tout le monde
dit qu'il est hyper compétent est-ce
qu'elle aurait été autant détesté par le
public qu'une femme jeu c'est pour cela
que j'ai trouvé ça l'fun essayer de
trouver une façon de garder son pouvoir
puis sa fermeté et pour personne venu
mettre son nez dans un encadrement
tout en y amenant une humanité qui
serait quel public pourrait s'y attacher
été parce que c'est ça on aime beaucoup
sur calais les femmes sont gentilles
pical son profil on n'aime pas ça mais t
es pas là pour être filmé elle pour
venir poste de police ça va bien avec ta
jalousie sur l'a31 avec des caméras
s'allume je voudrais que jamais j'ai
suivi rumeurs avec ma copine de l'époque
et moi j'étais geneviève brouillette
dans ce rôle important vraiment je crois
que c'est le rôle le plus marquant de ma
carrière des merveilles autiste est
facile ça cool est source dans ta que ça
a été comme une rencontre merveilleuse
et à chaque fois encore aujourd'hui
parce que je suis vraiment étonné il ya
pas un mois qui passe sans que quelqu'un
ment pas les gens se retape pour la
cinquième fois la série où des jeunes
l'écoutent sur tou.tv puis ils se
retrouvent aussi bien à chaque fois je
rencontre quelqu'un qui aime rue marges
elles l'aiment parce que je me dise tu
capable de 4 estime aulas a été déjà en
cela c'est sûr que je vais t'aimer vous
êtes un magnifique exemple de résilience
parce que après vos études en 1989 vous
êtes sortis de l'option théâtre du cégep
de saint-hyacinthe l'effet des élections
quat'sous qui ne se sont pas déroulées
comme vous le souhaitiez comment vous
avez réussi à rebondir à vous trouver
des séries comme blanche la presse
ça décolle il pèche 6 être un artiste
c'est beaucoup une question de ténacité
mais une carrière d'artiste et se faire
dire non
90% du temps il ira oui qu'on a mais sur
le canton des chances us ça m'amène ici
moi voilà d'avoir district là je pensais
sincèrement que c'était fichu c'était
terminé
puis je me demandais ce que j'allais
faire de ma vie parce que bien sûr ça
fait 30 ans que toute mon énergie et
toute mon intelligence et il me
rechercher tous se sont tournés vers le
métier d'actrice dans lequel elle sait
quoi faire d'autre selon laquelle je
serais pas là puis j'ai eu comme seul
mais à chaque fois on allait presque se
terminer plus fous si zac deux fois le 2
mai justement d'essayer positif du
cirque âme sa force de vente en europe
il agit des fois je m'amuse et je
regarde maintenant les oscars plus je
regarde qui qui pour l'instant lui qui
tannait contournable deux ans le passé
quand ça partout pour tout le monde
quand on a passé sept en réalité ma
dernière question parce que vous devez
retourner sur le plateau de tournage
geneviève brouillette la comédienne
habitants campagne à lecteurs la ville
de montréal loin du bruit de la ville
cela vous permet de vous ressourcer pour
devenir plus forte lorsque les caméras
ça l'est vraiment vraiment mitigée une
petit qu'on doit montréal est ma vraie
maison et dans les cantons de l'est
c'est la nature tout ça c'est ce qui me
permet d'avoir du recul de décrocher
pour ne pas prendre les choses de façon
trop dramatique ou trop parce que ça
risque relaxe c'est juste la télé j'aime
bien brouiller de cette entrevue était
comme un morceau de gâteau chocolat
merci beaucoup merci